community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
southwest medical the sponsors of this
next segment are continuing their 50th
anniversary celebration by shining light
on another local organization and this
one takes care of our animals
welcome to las vegas now dr zarath of
southwest medical hillary gray of the
animal foundation we are still
celebrating southwest medical's 50th
anniversary bringing partnerships
together to help the community so dr
zarath let's start with you what do you
do for southwest medical i joined the
southwest medical team of factory
providers back in 2018 and i specialize
in family practice in addition to being
a family physician i also serve as a
core faculty at our family medicine
residency program where we train 30
young physicians to join the workforce
after three years of their training of
course we're not alone in caring for our
communities and that is why we are
taking this year southwest medical's
50th anniversary is an opportunity to
share with other community partners who
have also have had a strong history of
giving back to our community well that
brings us to hillary hillary tell us a
little bit more about the animal
foundation and what you guys do for our
pets here locally first really want to
thank southwest medical for their
support what a wonderful partner the
animal foundation is non-profit
organization and we run one of the
largest regional animal shelters in the
whole country we cover all of the las
vegas valley and much like a public
hospital
we are the public shelter so we take in
all animals
you know we see
all kinds of conditions when animals
come in
very unfortunately sometimes we see
abuse cases or animals in need of
medical that hasn't been addressed so
our mission is really a life-saving
mission to make sure that every animal
that comes to us gets loving care
and hopefully gets a pathway to a real
strong forever home wow well thank you
so much for all that you guys do at the
animal foundation um how can people help
the first thing you can do is you can
adopt um summer is coming it's very busy
and so we're seeing a lot more animals
in the shelter
that also means that there are hundreds
of animals that you can meet and open
your heart to and take into your home
a lot of them
already
more senior animals a little bit older
that have some training that have been
around
kids and uh different folks so that you
know that they'll be an instant
wonderful family member there are some
others that are going to need a little
bit more of a loving touch
the second thing is fostering
if you can foster a pet if you're not
ready to adopt
we really would like to get as many pets
out of the shelter quickly as possible
and into kind of a home environment and
fostering is just one of the many ways
that people can volunteer with us
we have a ton of volunteer jobs in the
shelter everything from administrative
things to working with our behavior and
enrichment team to being a part of that
adoption process finally since we're a
non-profit donations are very important
wow i know for sure hillary someone out
there is watching and wants to help
after that explanation so um how can how
can they do that is there a website or
somewhere they should go to find more
information
yes we have a website that's full of
resources it's
animalfoundation.com you can find out
how to volunteer you can donate you can
browse all of our adoptable animals and
hopefully find your next forever friend
here's to the next 50 years of both of
your organizations thank you so much
thank you thank you
thank you again to southwest medical for
sponsoring that segment and being one of
our community pride partners